I'm gonna I mean and I think maybe it's
best to just talk to your neighbor for a
couple of minutes so you can figure it
out and then maybe I'll discuss the last
one because it's the only one that's
sort of non-trivial
I mean Lester
despite all that reveals was one of the
best
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay so since the reception is in two
minutes does everybody wanna they wanna
rent illusion
[Music]
[Music]
to D minus 1 to the our corresponds to
just walks in a tree all walks none I
mean non by tracking walks in a tree
would never come back
the second term on the homework I mean I
think maybe the hint is just to count
all walks mr. count all walks in the
tree
anybody get the first one yeah it's
basically the map operator in this case
so the first one is so my dinner
identity that we originally used to
prove this which ultimately is just the
same as a map operator but we didn't
realize so the first one is almost
identical to what I did in lecture it's
just the map operator restricted to the
Z variables I know but remember we did
map and set Z to be equal to minus 1
[Music]
okay I don't mean this is not literally
map on all polynomials but on this
polynomial time wait for this
restriction okay I guess that's hope
that's almost a true reality because I
know we know this is equal to naught but
there's a way to see that by it that
would the restriction yeah
so I mean okay the reason I put the
first problem is that this form of this
identity is useful for controlling the
roots of these polynomials which I'm
going to use tomorrow in the Catalan
singer
anyway I guess I'm keeping everybody
from their beer so that's just